all right next good Trump story
a Donald Trump has released a bizarre
incredibly hyperbolic attack on Senate
now minority leader Mitch McConnell and
this is delightful this is just
delightful so remember that on Monday I
told you about the growing and Brewing
Civil War happening within the
Republican party what were the two sides
of the Civil War I explained on Monday
well one side is trumpist Republicans
all of whom voted against the bipartisan
infrastructure bill passed by the house
on Friday Trump is Republicans who said
we don't want this we're not helping Joe
Biden we're not doing any of it on the
other side of the Republican civil Civil
War were the 13 Republicans who crossed
party lines in the house and did vote
for the tiny comparatively tiny
infrastructure bill
um uh passed by the house on Friday 13
Republicans crossed party lines the
trumpist Republicans went nuts demanding
the removal and promising to primary and
ruin the careers of those 13 Republicans
who said this is a bill that I'm going
to vote for and I said at the time let
him fight encourage them to fight this
is what the left needs because quite
frankly things aren't looking
particularly good for the left right now
in the aftermath of last Tuesday's
elections looking at 2022 the left needs
something Democrats need something
Democrats in the left they overlap a
little but they are two different things
but it's not looking good for either
right now so this is good well we have
another could we call it a rejoinder in
the Republican Civil War Donald Trump
has released a statement trashing Mitch
McConnell for not passing infrastructure
while he was President remember much of
why Trump is opposed to Republicans
helping pass infrastructure now is
regardless of whether it would be good
for the country and Trump said while he
was President it would be good for the
country Trump doesn't want this to be a
victory for Biden because Trump wasn't
able to get it done and so Trump doesn't
want any Republicans to help Joe Biden
because by helping Biden it makes
Trump's lack of passing infrastructure
while he was president look worse
is that true yeah maybe to some degree
maybe to some degree but as Business
Insider points out it was Trump who
walked away from a two trillion dollar
deal back in 2019. take a look at the
statement from Donald Trump released
yesterday through his save America pack
Donald Trump said why is it that old
crow Mitch McConnell voted for a
terrible Democrat socialist
infrastructure plan now by the way
if Joe Biden's 1.2 trillion dollar plan
is socialist how is the two trillion
dollar deal that Trump seemed to want
but ultimately walked away from how is
that not doubly socialist because it's
BS that's that's why
um Trump going on to say
and induced others in his party to do
likewise when he was incapable of
getting a great infrastructure plan
wanting to be put forward by me and the
Republican Party he continuously said he
couldn't get it passed just like I had
to go around him to get the very popular
southern border wall built which caused
Great delay but could now be completed
in one month by Biden I think there's
three lies in that sentence all of the
infrastructure money two trillion
dollars would have gone into real
infrastructure Rhodes Bridges tunnels
airports Etc also why did Mitch give the
Democrats a two-month Hiatus just long
enough for them to figure it all out
when they were completely ready to fold
this is an unhinged man
um it was TR again it was Trump who
walked away from that two trillion
dollar deal he says it was McConnell
Business Insider also writes about this
um in May 2019 Democratic leaders in the
Trump administration had a productive
round of negotiations around a floated
two trillion dollar infrastructure
package but the deal crumbled over the
democratic-controlled house
investigations into Trump after the
release of then special counsel Robert
Mueller's report during a second meeting
with house Speaker Nancy Pelosi and then
Senate minority leader Chuck Schumer
Trump walked out within three minutes of
negotiations
instead of walking in Happily to a
meeting I walk in to look at people that
just said I was doing a cover-up I don't
do cover-ups Trump said at a press
conference
um
yeah so remember it was Trump that
walked away now Trump says he was
justified in walking away but that he it
was still Donald Trump who walked away
from that negotiation so why is this
good well it's good because things are
looking really bad for Democrats right
now things just aren't looking good
you've got a contingent of the left that
might describe itself as the progressive
left although I am on the Progressive
left and I think that we should actually
be working with Centrist Democrats to
extract any victories that we can but
you've got a portion of the progressive
left that still has a sort of burn it
down accelerationist mentality
that is going to hurt Democrats in their
possibility of getting anything done
Democrats are terrible at campaigning
and the McAuliffe campaign in Virginia
just a disaster it's looking really bad
for 2022 is the point and right now I
think if we had a Trump versus Biden
election held today I think Trump wins
easily
um so the biggest gift that Republicans
can really give Democrats right now is
to fight amongst themselves it's a
really sad commentary on the state of
the democratic party I'm not denying
that it is it is wild that the best
thing Democrats have going for them
right now is that Democrats that
Republicans rather are fighting with
themselves Trump Republicans fighting
with the Republicans that voted for
infrastructure Trump Republicans
fighting with Mitch McConnell because of
uh his actions in the Senate it's sadly
and this is I mean listen
you know I'm not I'm not a Democrat as
many of you know I don't care about the
Democratic party this is a really
embarrassing moment for the Democratic
party given that the most optimistic
thing anybody can point to is
Republicans seem to be damaging
themselves
it says very little about
democratability to get anything actually
done
um but it's a good thing that this is
happening for the country in the sense
that a distracted Republican party a
divided Republican party is a Republican
party that will struggle to get anything
done and may also even struggle to
obstruct the things that Democrats want
to get done we'll see we'll see but
encourage the Civil War and it doesn't
seem to be stopping anytime soon
your internet activity and data is being
observed by a variety of parties they're
selling your information they're
deciding what you can access don't let
it happen to you I use Atlas VPN to keep
my internet traffic private from isps
Tech platforms online marketers even
governments and Atlas VPN keeps me
protected against hackers people
eavesdropping on networks to steal your
information if I turn on Atlas VPN
before logging into Netflix Hulu or
Amazon I can access streaming content
from other countries I can even watch
stuff from Argentina like soccer I use
Atlas VPN on all of my devices you
install it you turn it on once and then
you just forget about it and enjoy your
privacy you can read online about why
vpns are so important to use every day
really something you should have and
Atlas VPN is having a huge Black Friday
sale giving you 86 percent off comes out
to like a dollar 39 a month for a
subscription plus you'll get three
months free just go to atlasv dot PN
slash Pacman the link is down below